northern Australia is a hotbed of exotic
animals including the frilled lizard the
frill is that rough like collar it uses
to bluff its enemies like feral cats now
here's the frill at half-staff look
let's go all the way with this thing
let's pretend you're a predator are you
ready to see the frilled lizard in full
scare mode okay collar boy let's see
what you got hey hey watch it as you can
see the whole point of this exercise was
to get the frilled lizard on the run
because a frilled lizard on the run is
one of nature's most offbeat
entertaining sites I mean check out that
leg action the way it runs pumping its
back legs akimbo has earned it the name
bicycle lizard
the point of the scary frill is to give
the lizard enough time to beat a hasty
retreat rocketing up the nearest
arboreal loft